[Applause]
this is not our interest song I was
listening what the hell is literally
nothing other than starting a podcast
that would have stopped
[Music]
[Music]
do you guys snack often would you like
to snack better while having things that
taste great and aren't horrible for you
will nature box is your solution they
deliver delicious snacks over a hundred
of them to your front door you select
them online and they send them to you
it's very simple and they have delicious
snacks the crunchy barbecue twists
strawberry lemon-aid fruit stars I mean
I can go all day all right now go to
naturebox.com/tyler Julian for 50% off
your first order
that's half off your first order healthy
snacks easy to get to you little legwork
I'm all about no legwork all about just
eating okay I don't want to go to the
start mail it to my house I'm hungry
naturebox.com/tyler Julian 50% off first
order thank you and also sponsored by
lift guys if you're trying to choose a
ride-sharing company to drive for they
need drivers okay if you're trying to
choose one a drive or go with the one
that believes in treating the air
drivers better which is why lyft drivers
earn nine out of ten rides with five
stars that's a great stat red nervous
and they're looking for drivers so if
you need work and you need to just earn
a couple bucks on the side lift is a
great kick okay you keep all the tips
you cash out instantly it's all great
right now when you go to ly ft.com
lift calm / annejulien you score
yourself a $500 new driver bonus we just
want to clarify this is for people who
are looking to drive for a lift this is
not a code for riding for live because
we've had a couple tweets that were
confused looking for $500 in drive and
ride credit so that's not my business
it is a great deal hello listen to the
podcast try to take lives up to $500
I'd like I'd like a ride to San
Francisco now as you probably had no
idea we just got back from we're not
matching if you're listening to the
podcast and you don't have the window up
on YouTube don't bother watch it we're
not matching yeah me so relax on the
back I don't know why you can't show
them the back no I can't
mmm Wow it says jenna julian on the back
because they gave out shirts to the
twitch partners that were there and
since our twitch channel name is Jenna
Julianne our say Jenna Julianne pretty
dope and though we match I can't turn
around do you guys want to know why yes
I can you said I couldn't I stand
monetized more than that you been
whatever
Jenna's got a hole in the back of her
sweater no one knows well it started as
one and then I became too these are like
some of my favorite sweatpants ever
they're these like blue I don't know
what this brand is called love I think
it's called party hard no it's not
what not at all I got them with Julian
one day
forever ago like right when first
started dating and my brewery like we
went out to brunch
we got mimosas and then we're gonna walk
back to my house and there was a store
on the way called top to top that sells
like running in athletic gear and stuff
perfect for the Sunday after getting
hammered ASIMO so yeah we're like you
ought to go drug shopping like funds we
went into top of top and we bought some
socks about these weapons
and they are definitely there over there
cancelled so it's four years for almost
five years in the making they've had it
yeah well so I started getting like you
might have put them on like I knew that
they had holes like they're not
sweatpants I could wear out in public
because they had like the like the
bottoms ripped like they have holes like
all over the legs and stuff just from
being a really soft material and also
Kermit by trying to bite my leg every
time I leave the house and then but I
watched it he's put miles in those just
him alone yeah
so I knew that they kind of had a hole
in like one hole in the back like by the
waistband and then I put them on
yesterday and I realized that they were
tearing on both butt cheeks like bull
butt cheeks were tearing open and then
we sat and i played pub g in them last
night
and they ripped like they're just like
the piece in the middle is still intact
like the seam down the but is still
intact but both cheeks over all the way
yeah well chinks all the way down this
long pants you guys don't get to see it
but as you can imagine it's not it's not
too hard on the eyes
it's like cockpit comfortable it's kind
of cute but I haven't taken them off
it's inappropriate for being in public
but for me it's kind of a look the dog
didn't appreciate it yeah it's a I guess
you could call them buckle pants
butthole pants yeah that's off the time
but the hole is covered hole pairs by
the strip of fabric in the middle yeah
but you know I'm not talking about
butthole I'm talking about butt hole mm
hole but well my pants that's what it is
let's do that hold that pants okay yeah
when I walked in here chilly was like
just because we were we were rolling
okay and we we have a company that helps
us with the post-production of the
podcast so once we do like finish
recording we drop the footage and they
like put to all the effects of
everything so I was like Jenna just be
careful when you walk in the room
because we're rolling and like you're
wearing those pants they're just maybe
like she like slid into the room so
that's why I was playing this and
walking in
with my but not facing the camera hold
my piss oh my pants I like them okay
they're nice how do you do can you smile
all the time yeah I'm waiting right now
look you can repin me one more here oho
okay not too much no wait no Tommy
that's the new fashion trend it's gonna
happen whole but pants - Katy I'm just
sitting on my foot and it's just my butt
Cuba thanks anyway
we just got back from twitchcon last
night he spent like the day there we
didn't we didn't do more than one day
and twitchcon was interesting we we went
it was a little bit of a last-minute
decision but we as you guys know in the
last eight months have really kind of
kicked it up on our twitch channel we've
been streaming a whole lot more we've
been taking the stream a whole lot more
seriously we've been putting more time
and love into making it a great channel
that we like and a fun community for you
guys and so naturally when we were
offered to go twitchcon we were like
kind of intrigued because this has been
kind of a cool new movement for us and a
little bit of a pivot in our time and
space
you know entering the twitch world so we
went and we didn't really have a
meet-and-greet we didn't have any sort
of official things he just kind of
wandered around which already is a new
thing for us yeah so it was it was wild
it was um first of all I've never seen
someone in cosplay that was the first
for me which was really dope there's a
lot of cosplay I don't mean I don't know
there was like so much to kind of like I
I had a good time
overall it was positive for me yeah I
just think that sometimes like it can
get kind of crazy
yeah well see that's the thing is like
we didn't know what to expect like I
literally have not been to VidCon or
playlist since like 2013 and what she
means by that is she's never been in the
main yeah like you're not allowed to if
you really can invite creator you go to
like your meet and greets and then
sometimes they shut the floor down
Mercury
can go down there but I'm not allowed to
just go like walk around VidCon because
then it creates like a problem you
create like a traffic jam people start
just like running and doing weird stuff
which isn't safe here because
environment so that's been a rule at
VidCon and like a playlist for a long
time like whether or not people follow
that rule that's a rule right but I mean
it's in the contract
because it's meant not so that you have
a bad time or like can't experience
VidCon it's in it for the safety of the
children and the people that are
attending for their their own selves
like sometimes they just get excited and
then a bad situation is happening so I
haven't been to VidCon or playlist like
this past year when they like shut down
on the floor we walked around was like
one of the first times that I've seen
what it looked like in years because I
had never been on the inside and it was
really cool but um it was cool to walk
around a convention that was not for
YouTube and sort of see what that's like
because the only other convention that
I've been to
it will comic-con in 2009 in New York
City not even San Diego and the natural
foods Expo that we went to which was
totally different than any video
convention and that was the first time
that I had seen what the inside of the
Anaheim Convention Center looked like
not like the back hallway which was just
totally dressed up differently but yeah
but see so when we go to the natural
foods Expo it was sort of like with
twitch I didn't know 100% know like what
to expect you know in terms of my own
safety or other people's safety or
whatever you just don't know because
YouTube convention obviously the rules
are there it's like do not walk around
like in life usually it's like you're
walking around you're doing something
and people want to come up to you and
say hello it's always fine so ever a
problem it's nice to meet people the
Natural Foods Expo walk around no
problem like almost everyone there is
like they're for natural foods might get
a Hello it's not oh it's cool to see you
cool to meet you not a problem
whatsoever so there's like a big
spectrum there of like crowded
convention areas where it could go
either way and we like we had a fair
amount of people that said hello and it
wasn't like
problem or anything but it was a
different experience for us to go and
like walk around and not have it be like
VidCon yeah and it was cool to see in
other communities like big event you
know I mean we're in the twitch
community but we're like new to it yeah
and it was it was just really cool to
see it and how it worked and I mean one
day one huge difference that I know is
to treat him like a VidCon and twitchcon
was the meet and greet lines like we
know a lot of those people are it's
really exciting to see like your
favorite streamer like standing really
close to you like I get it I've always
gotten it get it with YouTube I get it
with VidCon it's like it's because I'm a
fan as much as I am the poster and
they're like they're right there
but like at twitchcon the mean greet
lines are not like the dominating force
is really off to the side yeah there's
not like it's very much an afterthought
yeah it's not they're not like four
hours long there aren't people in line
like sitting down and like camping out
for the day it's not like people are
screaming like the energy is chill the
people there are chill they seem much
older than a VidCon or a playlist and
you do because someone was like oh who
are you excited to see and I was like
well I mean if it's anything like VidCon
we're not gonna see anybody yeah well
yeah because if it's VidCon for us like
we go to our meet and greet then we go
back to her hotel or we'll go to the
party and then we'll go back to our
hotel like we're not allowed to just go
and like kick it you know and the only
people that meet you or like really good
to see you is if they coda like your
panel main stage performance or your
meet-and-greet cuz you can't just go
walk around yeah so I figured like
twitchcon is probably the same ways we I
would love to see doctor disrespect or
like shroud or other people that Julian
watches although this wasn't there but
um I was like we're not gonna see
anybody cuz don't they like don't they
have [ __ ] to do like we're just gonna be
walking around the convention floor yeah
but we did we thought we saw a [ __ ]
doctor disrespect and he was just sort
of stand it looked like it impromptu
meet-and-greet at sort of one yeah so
that like shocked me I was like oh my
god he's right there I didn't go up and
didn't ask a picture there's like a
group of people around him it was just
cool to be like that close to him and be
like wow
alright that's different because it
go to VidCon it's not like you're gonna
see you know [ __ ] Jake Paul standing
next to you or like Berkeley they're
either on the stage or you go to their
meeting grades yeah I think I think what
kind of took me by surprise was not only
the fact that the mean greets were so
like not an integral part of the the
experience it's just kind of like if you
want to go to being Greece sure but the
longest line I saw was like 30 people
yeah and it was like half the me and
Greece weren't even happened there was
like two at a time there was no there
was no like twitch I I didn't see a
whole lot of twitch employees but yeah I
mean we didn't know how it worked like
maybe those lines are short because they
were just gonna stand there all day yeah
and so people would go up when it looked
a little shorter or I have no idea
yeah or if it's there for a specific
time or like what the [ __ ] was for sure
and anyway yeah and also like us walking
around as much as it kind of surprised
some people I feel like as the the
bigger streamers on Twitch go to
twitchcon that's also kind of what they
do yeah kind of just walk around there
whether they're vlogging streaming or
just kind of hanging out there their
third day are there they're like amongst
everyone else and it's not like you know
if if the I because go driving there
like I have no idea at all what to
expect and I have recent become such a
huge fan like in the last handful of
months of like some of these streamers
like doc and all these people and I'm
imagining us walking into the halls of
twitchcon a lot of people not really
knowing who we are and just watching
hordes of people screaming after doctor
disrespect after he's like quartered
across and that's what I'm thinking is
gonna happen right we walk in and he's
at the design by humans booth and
there's like 30 40 maybe 45 50 people
and there's all respect release and calm
just standing around and they're just
they're just adults they're just like
and not only their age they're just like
kind of behaving very common very
politely and it was so kind of like it
was just it shook me I was like this is
crazy how this functions like this and I
don't know what to judge it off of in
terms of like how twitchcon was last
year I've heard a lot of different
things because it was in San Diego and
stuff but it was very cool it was very
cool to see someone who I genuinely am a
fan of be in that environment be able to
meet their fans without an overwhelmed
it didn't seem like he was super
stressed no he looked like he must have
been very hot
yeah well he's in his some gear but I
don't know something about something
about the the eat the level playing
field of everyone at twitchcon it felt
kind of cool yeah it was like we could
walk through the halls doc was standing
in the halls all the fans are there all
these partners affiliates it's like
everyone's just found everyone's just
into Twitch and gaming and that's like
that's the umbrella over everyone in the
entire and obviously there were a couple
moments when it became a little hectic
because you know sometimes crowds form
around you and we're not really prepared
for that at an event like that we don't
have security and whatnot but for the
most part I mean it was great and we you
know we stopped by the there was like an
HP Arena where they played pub G and had
tournaments and we watched and I
actually am sort of internet friends
with Lauren
pansy one of the announcers and it was
cool I like waved to her and they it was
like they said hi to us and we like
stood there and it was like this really
cool like Hunger Games
esque like kind of set up are these
people who are competing we're in these
little glass booths and you could look
at them while they were playing and then
he would watch the main and it was that
was [ __ ] rad I was like one of the
highlights I think that that was my
favorite part is because I've watched
like hearthstone and rocket League and
all different kinds of like eSports
events where it just looks [ __ ] rad
you're like well he's a stage or there's
people playing [ __ ] video games I
that's really cool and I would wonder
what it would be like to be there and
although we didn't really watch like a
whole lot of it it was an amateur
tournament it was still just cool to be
there and feel what it feels like to
watch a video game tournament live and
the environment and I liked it a lot it
was like I would [ __ ] if there was
like a big Turner something I would love
to go I think it'd be fun I agree and
like I think twitchcon was great for
that exposure just specifically for us
because before twitchcon I definitely
wouldn't have known like if I would have
wanted to go to something like that like
if I were to get if we were you invited
to like oh the next pub gee Invitational
or with this and that are we gonna get
sounds cool but I literally have no clue
what to expect so I'm just gonna turn
off the AC it just popped on it was
really and and and having seen that now
I'm like okay that could be really
[ __ ] around and I also
think that the fact that they allowed
amateur tournaments to happen at
twitchcon anyone can sign up and be in
those business that was cool I think
that was really wrapped well so I have a
question because I know I've heard it's
it's like doubled in size since last
year was last year the first year that
there was twitchcon I don't know well
because it felt a lot like the way that
VidCon used to be in like 2013 like the
I was shocked but it also made me a
little nostalgic of like my first VidCon
it was just like everybody walking
around doing anything like there was no
separation between creators is the
fourth one
okay there was no separation between
like creators and you know people are
going to the event yeah we're even like
the sponsors or you know everyone
everything together as a hodgepodge
it only got separated or like you know
turned meet-and-greet lines or like main
stage performances just due to purely
trying to organize it into something
like yeah you know people would be
having like what looked like what was
happening to Doc or like other people
they're having these impromptu meet and
greets like oh they're not super
impromptu they look rather impromptu but
I'm sure they were scheduled to some
extent maybe so but I'm saying the way
that they're just on the floor like just
happening yeah there's no guardrails
right you can just touch him if you
wanted yeah you're you're at an arm's
distance whatever saying like you could
you're there you're not behind a million
barriers there's no security I mean well
yeah because at VidCon they they buy or
purchase a specific or a lottery ticket
to try then they click in who they would
like to meet then they go into a lottery
system where you get a certain
meet-and-greet then they all have very
specific wristbands with the time and
you know people go early if they want to
be early in that line and you're
committing a couple hundred people that
get to meet that person and then
everyone else has to stand you know away
from those lines you can maybe see them
but like there's no chance for you to
meet them yes I mean where is that
Victor at twitchcon it looked like maybe
they did have a scheduled time yes
they're out on the floor but like
anybody could just sort of walk up there
and say hello or whatever it feels like
though that is what VidCon was in its
infancy and that maybe in the future it
will
turn more yeah just out of pure
necessity and out of safety which
although I will give twitch like
SuperDuper props because it there was a
very long line going in we got in a
little faster because we're twitch
partners but for the yeah the convention
goers the line was very long what's
going on and they had a metal detector
and they secured they checked everyone's
bags and they were doing a really
thorough security inspection on every
single person that went there which I
think I love that and the only reason
laughing is because when he said the
medal just everything it reminds me of
when we were walking through security
we had our bags checked I had everything
I had got patted down I walked in and I
look to my left and there's this girl in
full cosplay and the security officer is
inspecting this giant sword and she's
just like metal detecting it and it's
just like I don't know I can't I think
it's good yeah it's just like such a
funny concept like for people in college
yeah yeah no I I think I think
everything about twitchcon for me felt
like they had their [ __ ] together for
the for the event like every event
always can be improved right that's why
you know next year is always gonna be
better and a little different but I
thought the way they had it laid out and
we only saw I would say 50% of it yeah
and we were only there for one afternoon
and we got there at like at like 1:30 -
and stayed till 6 or 7 I don't even know
and um and it was great we the h1z1
Arena we don't plays when Z 1 but that
[ __ ] arena are you kidding me we saw
my emails he was commentating there that
was one of the highlights of my life boy
we saw Mighty Mouse
Demetrius Martin he is he's oh my god
sorry oh my god he's defending his title
how many times now 11 I think 12 12
times we was there in the flesh trying
his best and he did so wonderfully
announcing the h1z1 well I um so I knew
he was gonna be there cuz I like follow
him I didn't know what you was gonna do
there I thought he might have been just
like doing a mean green and we're
sitting there in the arena and I'm like
that sounds like mine yes look he's like
far away and
it's him he's like we're in the headset
he's like it was cool it was cool to see
him not in an MMA setting also yeah it
was really bad
but I mean I think that the thing that
was like the coolest to me the most was
like Andy Milonakis is a legend he's
been a legend since forever and even
Andy Milonakis is walking around
live-streaming twitchcon yeah you mean
without a problem yeah so I mean but I
think the the best word I could describe
it in comparison to VidCon is chill yeah
it's like old-school video it's a chill
version of VidCon for gamers you know
yeah and I think I think it's crazy to
think about but I genuinely believe that
twitchcon is only gonna get bigger
yeah and twitch is getting bigger I
agree like seeing what doc and some of
these guys like shroud have done for
twitch and kind of brought this whole
new life into the platform showing a new
group of people like what twitch could
be is only gonna keep expanding it to
bigger and bigger you know stars and I
think it's it's really rad because I
love it it's like twitch is one of the
things that I've you know aside from
YouTube because I you know when I first
started making YouTube videos and you
started helping me and I was helping you
and pop one of the things you kind of
helped me realize it's like you got to
watch YouTube you got to start becoming
like the Internet and that led to me
becoming a fan naturally of some
youtubers and I think this is the second
kind of the rebirth of that if you will
my name is vine me becoming a fan on the
Internet of like watching streamers like
I'm I'm is fine too but I just feel like
it's cool to feel like we're a part of
something on both sides of it yeah no
we're creators but we're also big fans
of a lot of these streamers and it's
cool - I just think twitch is [ __ ]
awesome and I it's been really rad in
you ain't nervous when you said like
Julie was nervous I don't think Julie's
ever gotten excited and fanboy but when
I fan by I just shut down yeah I don't
know why people in the past are like oh
do you want to take a picture of the
price someone I don't I can't
yeah like everyone else went up to meet
and
we breathe the same air we good yeah
exactly like me and doc we have a good
thing going right now he's never heard
my name or heard me talk like I love it
like it's perfect I don't want to [ __ ]
that up yeah I was [ __ ] around though
and it was also cool to see in the flesh
just even from afar like a couple
streamers i watch and maybe we'll never
talk to ya the only thing that did suck
was the internet and the self-service
because of the massive amounts of people
AT&T what the hell what the hell I
didn't get a lick of service themes it's
like when you go to a baseball game or
like a basketball game or something in a
big arena with lots of people and then
nobody's [ __ ] phone yes it's it was
like that the entire day yeah yeah well
I mean it was awesome and shout side to
twitch and for you know helping us get
there and giving us these cool jerseys
yeah I like our jerseys more toys
we're twitch comma partner Wow
I watch you get out all right I'll leave
tomorrow morning no no go back away no
[Music]
I'll leave in the morning
no he's going on last-minute trips mom I
really don't want to leave she doesn't
want me to leave I don't want you to
leave I'm gonna leave in the morning
I'm leaving in the morning no yes okay
no you already said okay first of all
first of all you not leaving no I know I
know we we took a little time off of
last-minute trips and we're back we're
throwing the dart actually by the time
you're watching this we're gonna be in
our destination what you don't know yet
which I don't know where that will be
we'll be shooting all day today for you
yeah we took a couple months off and I'm
really really excited to get back and do
it although I hate leaving Qatar and
missing you but it's kind of part of the
process no I'm leaving I think you stay
I can't I can't
it's again I can't yes you can no I
can't
yes again no yeah I can't
yeah I don't like when Julie leaves cuz
I I literally feel like I just like kill
time until you're back
you know we're gross I'm serious I like
miss you know I know I miss you too
are you kidding me I feel like I feel
like we spend so much time together and
so many people have talked to you about
like the fact that we spend all our time
together
they're like they always tell me like
that's the exception to the rule of like
people who spend time together in a
relationship most people just get sick
of each other and we are that way I
literally do never get sick of you so
that's what makes leaving even for a
couple days kind of difficult but I
appreciate you letting me leave to chase
a dart around the United States you know
you should do is you should respect my
wishes and well you could come with us
if you should come with know if you sign
up as a lyft driver register you could
be the lyft driver that we call on there
and know what you're leaving in your
Segway in the middle of my sentence
saying that it's possible lyft are
concise Jenna Julian I'm gonna show
everybody my boy on camera yes I take
the Segway back then you know the only
thing with these pants
but like big enough for my whole boob to
go through yeah okay so they need me big
big I didn't say anything
what did you say big holes Julian did
you take the green tape off of this
money it was pissing people off
yeah me too thank you for listening to
us I listen guys just I'm not just your
guide I also listen Julian TM I listen
to you guys also we're cops
I'm a cop Danny belt put your hands up
we get to play that game again soon okay
um can I was in the Segway yeah go ahead
right now guys if you're looking for
work lift is looking for drivers and
they are a great ride-sharing company
you go to lift calm Scott Shannon Julian
you get a $500 new driver bonus when you
sign up using that URL and you get
started whenever you make your own hours
you literally turn on driver mode and
you can go pick people up make some new
friends make some tips cash out
instantly with the Express pay it's I
mean it's wonderful and like I said
before nine out of ten lift rides earn
perfect what do they earn new driver
bonus a perfect five star rating almost
they it's really awesome like I
definitely feel like when I when I take
a lift which is all the time now I I'm
blown away by it like how positive the
experience is with it with the drivers
and you guys you earn tips and no driver
bonus that's not the right line this is
why you read this message that's why I
read the sponsor you guys are in tips
within the app which is super convenient
when you get tips they add up really
quickly
and they go right into your pay so when
you cash out using Express pay instantly
you don't have to wait weeks or days or
months to get paid you get paid right
away which is huge driver bonus okay
lyft was the first ride-sharing company
to introduce tips into their app and
since then drivers had made 200 million
dollars since that was introduced that's
insane and they like I said they add up
you do a quick ride you a long ride they
add up right now guys go to lift calm
that's ly ft.com slash Jenna Julianne
all right seriously it's gonna be
awesome if you need a new gig just try
it out it's it's easy alright and it's
using our URL also if you're driving for
long hours you're gonna get hungry oh my
god it's a Segway I'll go to
naturebox.com/tyler and Julian get 50%
off get half off your first order of
snacks guys also goddam nature box is
over a hundred of delicious snacks that
taste amazing and are actually better
for you than the junk that we know you
might want instead this is better for
you and it tastes great I'm telling you
like we keep nature box in the house all
the time and it's a quick go to snack
when Kermit's crying
and is crying Kermit yes guys the
strawberry lemonade fruit stars are
still my number one favorite drafting
the jalapeno cashews are also incredibly
delicious for a nice little savory snack
with some shape and new snacks are added
every munch month which means mindless
munching whoa that's little tongue
twister
so guys new snacks all the time really
delicious stuff all right they pack
everything into the nice box and there
shows what your door when you open the
door I like this song sponsor we talked
about drew on the Shane podcast real
quick yes I was like oh that's a that's
like really cool that Shane has like
created this spot for drew and like we
listened to it obviously any I like drew
so much anything that he does on the
podcast we're gonna like yeah but he
genuinely contributes so much to that
show
yeah so much to that show goobie it's
sitting there listening to it for like
40 minutes you know it's Shane and the
guest and whoever talking and then all
of a sudden drew will just hit it with
it like be like what yeah it's like the
funniest [ __ ] like it really I really
feel like it was kind of like a pretty
significant change in structure when
they brought him in yeah it's like a
whole nother person that's like music oh
yeah and so like it's great at first it
was like wait what's going on but
absolutely I agree like he's totally
added so much to the show but he'll say
so and they're [ __ ] amazin oh but
perfectly time my favorite thing he does
is when he makes little songs about
sponsors yeah I love that I wish I could
be so cool you know who also does that
well sleep with me podcast who by the
way yeah it's not him he like I think
what they do is they like they have
people who are responsible for that each
week so he has like someone is really
good and I can make songs so make the
sponsors I'm good at me should we try
making sponsor songs wait just give me a
sponsor this will be a rough cut give me
a sponsor naturebox
we need music though what yeah maybe in
the future or not right now just the
brainstorming so good all right what's
what's your song I have to do it now
yeah hey you have to give me a beat no
no I want the high ones DJ spin that
track it's late at night but I don't
want to do it alone I need a driver with
Rick let's this one I'm gonna drive it
for a drive for a bit let's lift is
where I'm gonna meet cool people earn
tips and cash up instantly and I'm gonna
drive drive wait into the land rest with
me
oh my god for me the rest of the day I
was hungry and it was all fall day with
my wife was born
[Applause]
[Music]
get your hands back track crews I any of
our maybe international viewers I have
no idea what that is just like one of
those local jingles that plays only on
your literally injury attorneys but they
play like that with commercial plays
like countrywide it just goes selena and
buys injury attorneys but they recently
like split up and the internet was like
meeh meeh on it a little bit cuz it was
funny like oh no they broke up yeah so
tag them tweet at them right now I have
a membership to 24-hour fitness but I
only go a really normal time so we know
from three hoses locations from bursts
twitch.tv Sausalito holler us people
have
and then I don't dry them off I'm
Cellino I have a nice piece she called
me and told me that was the longest I've
ever done that voice boy will you fight
it these are my glasses
then actually you're upside down oh okay
we'll agree to disagree that's fine with
me
agree to disagree all right Julian
youyou got a game for us to play because
I feel like it's your time to shine
you're in a trolling mood troll it up
mr. monk I'm not gonna be as good at
this as you are it's mine but it's all
the way out this game is called this is
[ __ ] hot in here because we have
these lights guys oh we need we need new
lights we have these lights that just
make it so [ __ ] a lot we need like
LED panels or something like Bakey
this this game is called fortunately
unfortunately it's basically like we
start a story and then she adds on to
the story with his sentence except the
sentence has to start fortunately and
then my sentence has to start with
unfortunately my gameplay in the
comments like that'd be fun is fun yeah
yeah yeah yeah please play in the
comments okay cuz there's gonna be way
funnier than ours but we're gonna start
it and every once in a while you can pop
that on okay okay a boy a boy named
Jennifer got lost in the mall and
couldn't find his mom hmm
trying to go fast okay fortunately she
was just a couple of doors over anything
else done so it's not like she was super
far away unfortunately
what started as a normal mani-pedi
turned into an armed robbery situation
which she decided to just go
and take all the nails fortunately
[Music]
unfortunately lost his mom for so long
fortunately this was [ __ ] this story
just got real fast this your money just
kidding oh my what alright fine go ahead
you're gonna like this one okay
jacksFilms turned on his camera to film
a video but that an earthquake hit
fortunately all of his camera gear was
right under a fault line in his house
and it all got smashed that's
unfortunate no it's fortunately
unfortunately his $10,000 dog ran away
in the middle of the earthquake all he
had left with his $1 dog oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
he was just stuck with Klondike is that
the $1 one yeah
yes fortune for unfold oh you're back -
fortunately that dog knows how to [ __ ]
unfortunately he knew how to [ __ ] - well
and knocked up way too many dogs and he
was lost
fortunately jack smell it's now
jacksFilms is now puppy mill oh my god
what have I done
that's all unfortunate this whole story
started unfortunate and then ended
unfortunate was hard yeah it's it's
difficult let's do it again
let's do it again no thank you
a man was pulled over by the police and
the policeman was his dad fortunately
his dad was really drunk I didn't
recognize his son so he didn't know he
was in trouble
unfortunately he was so drunk he pooped
and peed in his pants
fortunately that's his partner's kink so
his squad partner in the car was just
super Tom - that over oh [ __ ]
unfortunately he got everywhere
fortunately the son decided to turn on
his dad and take his badge and then go
to the police station to get his out
fired with this collar unfortunately
[Applause]
[Music]
fortunately we have some points to fall
back on
can never come back to them so you're
saying that Selena Barnes yes now
Cellino is creating insurance fraud yes
as a law firm they are they're investing
their time and money into insurance
fraud yeah that's why they broke up
because one of them was like look here's
the plan okay
we're gonna run around we're gonna do a
bunch of [ __ ] up [ __ ] but then we'll
be the injury attorney and it can never
come back to us because we're the
attorney actually like a really dark
brilliant plan so we know it bonds we
commit crimes but we can't ever get
caught for them because we're attorneys
Cellino is my name barn socks he never
wants to go get churros with me anymore
all I do is eat churros I'm getting sick
all the time so delicious I can't stop
the stereotype they're cops like donuts
are incorrect because I'm a cop and I
like churros only churros catch up on my
churro vegetable broth with my Toros as
the strawberries on a Sunday top two
churros instead I try my police baton
for churros instead of a dryer sheet
just throw in there I wash my clothes
with churros I was but a jar of my bar
what is Barnes like stealing his best
friend's wife spill Morty I don't know
the [ __ ] oh yeah yeah he's a poke those
how you really feel
I don't like him why not cuz I don't
like him at all
oh why cuz he doesn't like churros any
stuff with my wife come you don't talk
about it anymore
let's arrest him I'm a cop okay can I be
your new partner so you know turned into
Celino in Jenna we fight crime and we do
crime and we attorneys
what if can we just talk normally what
if a cop yeah started a twitch channel
yeah undercover Wow like live PD but on
twitch but but like they gamed too like
they had a whole fake persona and they
were a cop but they like they were in
just a deep deep undercover mission
trying to get in with some other
streamers and like you found this new
challenger like oh I like this guy I
like this girl like she's great or
whatever and you watched them for months
and months and months and then you find
them out when the big sting happens to
be a cop how incredible with that yeah
it [ __ ] des for you that's that's like
an episode because we were talking about
like with the IRL movement on twitch and
twitch getting bigger and [ __ ] there's
gonna be an SVU episode I'm sorry on on
twitch yeah an IRL specifically probably
you know what was hilariously cringe was
the twitch oh [ __ ] yeah we're gonna talk
about that the roast yeah
no the not only the roast but like the
tournament just the eSports like the
presentation of like being on stage and
like ruined the end like the winners
they're like put the wrong graphic up
and they're like they got the chat is
just roasting this guy he's just up
there he's being so awkward I I hate to
say it because it always happens this
way and like I'd hate to like agree with
like the stereotype of things but like
these sports like their presentation
when it comes like onstage [ __ ] is
always cringe yeah it's just always
cringe something always happens where
it's just it's not right it's just not
right and like I'm completely excluding
the play-by-play commentary
this that's like the most that they're
awesome especially the pub g11 when they
have the team of those two like but yeah
look anytime it's on stage they were
like announcing winners and they
accidentally put the wrong graphic on
stage so it like displayed you like
spoiled the winner for everyone is well
and they were like doing this whole like
man so when you were like going for that
long snipe like wow I like patient were
you being and he's just like I'm just
waiting until he poked his head no he
was like shot he's just like he was on
the open yeah I was his answer
right cool man alright so those were our
winner for the for the longest night
alright now get off this stage today
kept telling them to like leave this
stage so then they could bring more
people up going these overly energetic
like announcers are like broadcast
people with these broadcast boys talking
these a group a lot of times like really
introverted kids who like don't know how
to do an interview so they're like ask
them questions they're just like chill
video like one of them will be just kind
of like already be shy right because
they're not used to that and last this
really stupid questionnaire just like
and it's like a one-word answer and then
it's like okay like some people are like
wearing suits while they're like
announced if you guy are wearing just
like t-shirts what there was a guy named
jump and he was like wearing a suit he
was like hosting the twitch thing and he
was talking to the head of this company
oh man
giving H it's omen I think yeah by H
yeah and they were giving away this
laptop and they were talking about the
specs of the laptop he's like tell us
about this laptop that you can win right
now if you tweet hashtag whatever he's
like oh it's great it's like it's got an
i7 processor gtx 1070 who's bad athens
mechanical keyboard 144 Hertz like a
[ __ ] incredible gaming pc laptop and
he's like and it goes back to john he's
like yeah it's a little big but like
over here like what would you [ __ ]
say that dog it's a little big yo first
of all [ __ ] first of all [ __ ] we're
giving it away for free so shut up
second of all
it's a gaming laptop it's not supposed
to be thin it's not supposed to be a
little Kindle it's a little big but it
was so it was really funny though to
watch the that because we were watching
it here we weren't there we were
watching the live stream on Twitch but
all the comments are like oh my god this
is cringe and I was like it's not that
bad like it's pretty good and it's live
and it's like you know kind of new so
like give him a break and then I watched
some of it more and I was like oh [ __ ] I
just couldn't believe like there has to
be a better system then alright and the
winner is and then they give you an
award and like alright get off this
stage here's what I think the better
system is is like stop thinking that you
need to be traditional broadcast events
just stop doing it well maybe I'm like
don't don't put people in suits like
just stop with all the [ __ ] the weird
like trying to put yourself in the
[ __ ] TV box yeah it always ends up
badly and I feel like eastwards needs a
Joe Rogan desperately well honestly I
feel that because I'm forgetting the
name of Lauren's partner but Lauren
Scott the announcer for pub she and her
partner the red hair amazing they're a
great combo and their rapport is great
it's like the best eSports commentating
by far that I've seen yeah cuz like
there's two ends of the spectrum when it
comes to eSports commenting there's the
really overzealous like broadcast you
look Oh like look how hip we are we're
on video games and they just cringe all
the time and then there's the really
technical announcers who do a good job
of announcing the game but there's no
real personality to it like I'm talking
about like rocket League like when I
watched rocket League the our LCS those
announcers are [ __ ] spot on there
like so they know everything about the
game they're giving great technical
announcing play-by-play but it's like
there's no there's no heart it's like
there's more of just like it's it's
telling you what it is so like right in
the middle there is the pub gene that's
and where I felt like they've finally
hit that cool driver it's like yeah
they're like messing with each other but
it's not cringe it's like a genuine but
I agree that needs to there needs to be
a lot more personality yeah and the pub
G or the eSports announcer well I feel
like either of them although I do really
like them together maybe they're a bad
example as I did like them but like if
you had two people like them you could
split them up and you would have like
your Mike Goldberg who's like really
knowledgeable knows who they're talking
about maybe reads the sponsors maybe you
know does
segways or whatever and then you have
Joe Rogan who's just trying not to
[ __ ] swear the whole time cuz he's so
excited yeah you know any you need to
have someone super [ __ ] pumped up
these sports needs a Joe Rogan to at
least throw in every once in a while
like somebody that's just so hyped to be
there so hyped to watch the game that's
why we were joking about like me
commentating a pub G tournament or
whatever because like I when we when we
play the custom games on our channel I
oftentimes end up commentating the games
because I died and so I'm just spinning
around watching people and I get so
amped up anybody like fun but if you had
someone sitting next to you that was
like actually giving valuable
information technical things like
screaming swear yeah but like someone
that just is like really [ __ ] excited
yeah like when you when you listen to a
UFC fight and you would hear like
someone with Joe Rogan like they're
talking they're giving information like
a Dominick Cruz or like a former athlete
you know someone's there give
information or like and either of the
best yeah yeah wonderful at that but
like what really makes that fun and
dynamic and is what it's almost like oh
I don't know what he's doing it's like
he hears poked him in his eye like what
is going on yeah like you need somebody
like that to balance it out to make it
like more fun to listen to and while I
agree he's four C's gonna do it I just
I'm waiting for podgy to like optimize
their spectating mode so that that can
be a lot more fun to like comment and
share yeah and like some of the best my
most favorite like moments of our
streamers like when I've commentated on
crazy [ __ ] happening like I agree like
just the funny [ __ ] that goes down but
yeah it's I guess false circle it goes
back to to seeing the whole new world
that is twitch and twitch con and the
new games we like and it's all [ __ ]
exciting yeah it's all [ __ ] these I
watched a lot of the the hearthstone
championship to like I was losing my
[ __ ] mind
yeah and they're just like sitting there
talking about it so casually later like
there's not a quarter of a million
dollars on the line or like it's you
know what they're like a little excited
feel like I'm not sitting like a
horserace like it's gonna happen like if
something's going on and oh it's
happening like no it's like this is why
you kidding me like you you're funny
yeah they need like you mean someone
who's a genuine fan like I'm excited
yeah yeah they need an ESPN 8 the Ocho
bold strategy cotton let's see if it
pays off I think it jargon is is a great
like it's a great example of what what
it lacks yeah anyway thank you guys for
hanging out with us for another hour
this week we will see you guys next time
yeah I have holes in my pants
Jenna's Holzer piss I want to see you
guys if you can I don't know that game
made me didn't play it right but if you
guys want to do some of that in the
comments I would love to read it and
also every episode feel free to suggest
podcast ideas that you've may may be had
for a while or whatever that you want us
to check out leave them in the comments
we'll check it out you know in barns and
and if you're injured if you're injured
it's not gonna be okay because the Liam
principal's [ __ ] take everything you
have because it's just Cellino and he's
out for blood
that's my god alright alright guys bye
[Music]
you
[Music]